if you're having a hard time losing
weight total transformation who's the
sponsor of this next segment has the
solution i spoke with dr nash about a
few of her clients success stories and
how candida can be preventing the weight
loss
before dr nash i was a junk food junkie
in war size 14 but now i'm a size 6 8
and no longer addicted to junk food dr
nash you have to love norma because she
is no longer a junk food junkie welcome
to the show but tell us more about
norma's story yeah so first of all one
thing that i want to bring up that maybe
is a man you don't appreciate is the
size difference this woman went from a
size 16 to a size 6 8 as a result of
going through the work on my program and
identifying this special organism that
drives sugar and carbohydrate cravings
that knock most people off their game we
fixed it for her she lost the weight and
she keeps it off
okay what's this special organism thing
you were just talking about right so
there's this yeast or fungus that lives
in normal amounts in the body called
candida but when it overgrows it causes
a whole slew of problems including leaky
gut damaged immune system and stubborn
weight gain in fact it can cause weight
gain of up to 30 pounds a year so having
someone tell if they have candida what
are the symptoms of candida so
carbohydrate craving difficulty sleeping
brain fog difficulty losing weight these
are common symptoms that people feel but
there is a full prostate full proof test
that you can do right in the privacy of
your own home to find out if you've got
a candida overgrowth and if you do
then we need to get that corrected if
your goal is to lose weight and hold it
now you're talking about the spit test
how does this work
yeah the saliva test so what you want to
do is take a clear glass of water and
put some saliva in it first thing in the
morning before you put anything in your
mouth and watch it for 60 to 90 seconds
if you start to see this white debris or
filament coming down into the water
that's the actual yeast coming out of
your saliva and going into the water it
means you have an overgrowth and it
probably means your weight loss efforts
are being sabotaged okay so they do the
test they see the results they see
something that might be like candida
what do we do next so the next step is
we've got to do some kind of protocol to
get rid of the candida to allow your
body to reach its normal weight and hold
it and that's where i come in but the
first step is to do that online
evaluation but i help you design a
program that accelerates your results
and makes your body prove to you that
it's going to be able to hold the weight
loss afterwards before we get to your
special you mentioned the word proof and
i think the proof is here that your
programs work because your success story
80 pounds over 12 years ago you kept it
off you look beautiful what was your
secret
so my secret was going after the damage
instead of just the calories in calories
out approach only when i went after the
damage did my body finally give me the
ultimate end goal which is to get to the
normal weight and hold it what is the
special you have for us this week right
so of course when i come on the show i
always like to bring something special
to the las vegas now viewer so normally
that online evaluation is 97 if you were
to call my office directly but if you
take advantage of the website that we're
displaying on the screen i have set
aside 10 special spots but only 10 where
you can get it for under 10 dollars to
find out what's driving that weight
problem how to fix it and how to fix it
permanently
again you can call dr nash at
702-852-6888 or visit her online at
drnash.com
eval las vegas now we'll be right back